it's an exciting time the last few
minutes before launch
you as the the shuttle really comes
alive
and then all of a sudden you get this
big kick in the pants and
you look out the window and there's the
ground falling away and everything is
shaking
today on shock radio we're heading back
into space
my best friend from the second grade
after i became an astronaut
he said to me you know jeff this is
incredible you know i used to play
space man with you and now you're
actually going up into space
i'm your host sarah hansen and with us
this week is professor jeff hoffman
a former nasa astronaut over the course
of five
missions he's logged over 1 000 hours in
space
and yep some of those do include space
walks
professor hoffman teaches aeronautics
and astronautics at mit
but he's also committed to unlocking
this knowledge for the world
he's shared course 1600 introduction to
aerospace engineering on mitx
and 16885 engineering the space shuttle
which can be found on mitx and ocw
one of the things i loved about my
conversation with professor hoffman was
his take on perspective
and how a grander scale view like say
from outer space
can dramatically shift the way we live
here on earth
we fly so much in airplanes and probably
most people don't remember the first
time they look out of an airplane
window and see the earth i mean it's a
completely different perspective
that you get and and now rockets and
space travel which allow us to go
even farther and to try to give
people the perspective of looking at the
earth from
space is very important i mean
you know i was an astronomer i i know
the earth as a planet i mean
you know give me a break but
nevertheless when you actually
see it from the perspective of being in
space i mean imagine
you know you go up into space and you
look at this
thin blue line on the horizon which is
the earth's atmosphere i mean you go out
here from the surface of the earth on
a clear day and there's a big blue sky
and it looks like it goes on forever
and unfortunately that gives many people
the idea that
you know it doesn't matter what you put
into the atmosphere because it's so big
that
it can absorb it and it's the same thing
with the oceans and
when you finally get that gut feeling
of the finiteness of the earth you know
the oceans
the atmosphere and you realize we live
in a closed system
that the earth is a finite system um
that makes a difference because
exponential growth
cannot continue forever in a closed
system
professor hoffman's first expedition
into space
was in 1985. before that
he was actually doing work here at mit
launching telescopes into space
long before that though like many kids
since the second half of the 20th
century
he wanted to go to space himself
when i was a little kid i used to love
looking up
at the stars of course early part of my
life we lived in new york city
and more often it would be looking up at
the stars in the planetarium
but i was fascinated with that and
it was the dawn of the space age and
there were lots of
articles in newspapers magazines
television shows about the coming of the
space age and i
i ate it up um in fact
my best friend from the second grade
after i became an astronaut
you know he he said to me uh you know
jeff this is incredible you know i used
to play
space man with you and now you're
actually going up into space
it was a combination of the fascination
with
how far away things were and and the
fact that
by going up you got a completely new
view of things and
and also that space travel represented
the future
and and i found that really exciting so
then when the first astronauts started
to fly
uh you know they were our heroes and
i just wanted to go up there and look
down
unfortunately i soon realized that all
the
astronauts were military pilots and that
was not really a
career for me but that that desire to
you know look further out
to understand what's what's above what's
out there
uh that remained with me and and so i
ended up with a
degree advanced degrees in astrophysics
and
i was launching telescopes to look at
x-rays
and you have to go above the atmosphere
to look at x-rays that's what i was
doing here at mit
then nasa started to develop what was
then the brand new space shuttle and now
we're up to the the late 70s
and the thing about the shuttle was
they had a crew of seven and they only
needed two pilots so that was great
because that
that's what really opened things up for
scientists engineers medical doctors and
that's what gave me my chance and i
applied for it and was lucky enough to
get selected and
so then i could get the real overview
from space
five missions later and professor
hoffman is back on earth
and since 2001 he's been teaching a
series of courses on aeronautics and
engineering here at mit
luckily for us professor hoffman infuses
much of his nasa experiences and
learnings into his courses
to help his students really understand
the big picture
like he had to at nasa he emphasizes the
concept of
systems engineering understanding
systems engineering helps students and
astronauts alike
to tackle complex problems and it all
starts
by looking at the bigger picture
particularly
anything having to do with with space
with all
complex systems in general you know we
try to teach systems engineering
here you have to have the big picture if
you're going to be able to manage a
complex
engineering or scientific project
in in the aero astra department at mit
we
we don't really teach systems
engineering as a specific
subject until the graduate level because
really if you're going to be a
professional systems engineer and be
good at it
you really need a background in some of
the basics
of engineering so it's like at nasa and
mission control you don't start out
being a flight director you start out
working in one of the
individual disciplines and usually the
most successful flight directors have
worked in at least two disciplines and
then you understand how a discipline
engineer
approaches a problem and then you can be
more useful trying to get the the big
view of things
another really wonderful part of
professor hoffman's courses
is how they combine theory with real
hands-on experience
the majority of our students they they
are going to be working engineers
they're going to go out into the world
many of them get jobs in aerospace
companies and
they're going to build the next
generation of space vehicles
and we want them to have had some
experience actually
building something for instance here i
teach the freshman course
in introduction to aerospace engineering
and human space flight
and we have the students build a project
a lighter than air vehicle we you know
we give them the material
we give them some radio control
equipment
motors servos propellers and
kind of lead them through in in
a systems engineering way of going about
the project without formally telling
them that they're
practicing systems engineering i mean
even if you're going to be
a discipline engineer and just
concentrate on one aspect of a system
it still helps to have the concept
that you know somehow all these systems
have to play together
another way professor hoffman ensures
that these ideas really sink
in is with something called c d i
o cdio stands for conceive
design implement and operate and it's a
learning tool that helps students to
think through a problem
from to nuts as he puts it what's
wonderful about it
beyond the fact that it's helped us put
humans into space and on the moon
is that it can be useful in tons of
different contexts even beyond
engineering
the bottom line and the moral of all of
this is you really
need from the very beginning when you're
designing a system
to think about the end user you know
very often the people who design it
never have to use the system they they
come up with a design then they throw it
over the fence and
somebody else builds it and they don't
have to use it they throw it over the
fence and then the end user takes over
and so it's it's really critical so the
cdio
it's a way of approaching engineering
particularly complex systems that from
the very beginning
you take into account all of those
phases of
an engineering system i mean it's not
not just
engineering systems when you're you
build a house
i mean you know you better figure out
what it's going to be
to live in this house before it gets
built otherwise you're going to have a
lot of
you know bills with a contractor to make
changes at the last minute and that's
one of the other things you learn
in one of the basic principles of
systems engineering
and particularly in the space business
is that the further you get into
the implementation of the system the
more expensive it it
is to make any changes i feel like
that's one of the beauties of this
course
you might be working in a completely
different discipline but you can find
something useful
that is kind of the subtext of the
course is
it's not just about the space shuttle
it's learning
how a very very complex system
was initially conceived designed
implemented and operated and that's why
after the central part of the course
where we talk about the design and the
building of all these complex subsystems
then we brought in people who actually
operated the shuttle the
the launch director the flight director
the payload operator
an astronaut pilot who flew the shuttle
and and so on because
that's the final phase of the whole cdio
is from as i say from soup to nuts this
is what the shuttle was all about
to really understand the development of
the space program here in the us
it helps to look at the interconnected
series of systems that built it
and they go well beyond engineering and
mathematics
for example politics played a huge role
in aerospace engineering
we really thought it was important to
devote the beginning
lectures of the course to
you know what what were all these uh
influences which
had such an important impact on the
design
economically it was no longer possible
to treat nasa
uh in such a special way as had been
done by
apollo i mean 400 000 people working on
apollo with the
at the height of it four percent of the
federal budget going to space
exploration
this is not normal for space activities
it was a very special time in our
history
then you get to the late 60s i mean even
even john kennedy
after having made this commitment to go
to the moon started to have second
thoughts about how much it was going to
cost
then of course he was assassinated and
and getting to the moon
by the end of the decade be sort of
became our way of honoring kennedy's
legacy so so it wasn't question we did
it
but you know along came the nixon
administration
following president johnson's great
society program
huge increase in social spending and
then the vietnam war
and uh you know space it was clear and
nixon was explicit about this you know
the space program has to take
its proper role among all
other national priorities and and that
really involved a huge decrease
in nasa's budget and and the people
running nasa saw that coming and
and so how do you continue to explore
space
they were faced with the real
possibility that that human space flight
in this country might come to an end
and and nasa realized quite correctly
that reusability was a key
but then you get into all of the social
economic political influences
that put a lot of very very
tight requirements on the shuttle
particularly
since in order to justify the expense
nasa basically sold the shuttle as
capable of doing anything we needed to
do in space we could do with a shuttle
we used it for scientific experiments we
used it to launch satellites we used it
to
test out new engineering system we used
it to repair
satellites like the hubble space
telescope we used it to build the
international space station
for me all my flights were in the space
shuttle so
you know i look on it with a great
fondness
recognizing its limitations but also
understanding the incredible things that
it allowed us to accomplish
while professor hoffman's classes offer
incredible insights into what he's
learned at nasa
not to mention some deeply important
skills for any student or intrigued ocw
user
it's not every day that i get to sit
down with a real astronaut
so of course i had to ask him what it
was all like
being launched into space being in orbit
doing a spacewalk
before my first launch i i asked many of
the astronauts who had already flown
what's it going to be like they put us
in simulators and they shake the
simulator a little bit but they said you
know forget it that's nothing like the
real thing
it's hard to prepare yourself it's an
exciting time the last few minutes
before launch
you as the the shuttle really comes
alive
and then all of a sudden you get this
big kick in the pants and
you look out the window and there's the
ground falling away and everything is
shaking
and and tremendous noise people told me
that there was going to be more
vibration than i could ever imagine
and and they were right because i
couldn't imagine it
45 seconds later you're going straight
up and you break the sound barrier
and and that gives you even more
vibration because you get all these
shock waves and
i remember thinking to myself now this
can't be normal something
that the wings are going to fall off you
know this something's wrong
but i mean the structural engineers knew
what they were doing and the wings did
not fall off or else i would be
here talking with you with the shuttle
it was those two big solid rocket
boosters that caused all of the
vibration and they
they burn for the first two minutes once
they fall off
it's a really smooth ride i mean
everybody then talks about you know
there's
electric ride all the way up into orbit
so
yeah that that contrast between the
extreme vibration of riding on the side
of a solid rocket
booster and then just the burning of the
the hydrogen oxygen engines was was
really quite extraordinary
did anyone ever just get really scared
right before liftoff
there are some astronauts who will tell
you they don't like launches because of
the
the risk involved for me i mean i
remember before the first flight
riding out to the launch pad and looking
up at this incredible vehicle that i'm
going to get in
and thinking to myself first of all you
know this is not the time to be asking
yourself if you really want to do this
okay but then what was really going
through in my mind is
you know ever since i was six years old
and i saw flash gordon take off in his
rocket ship
in science fiction and i always dreamed
of doing it and i'm about to
uh you know leave the planet it was it's
exciting i mean so
my idea was you know sit back and enjoy
the ride
i'm not a pilot so i didn't have to even
worry about flying the shuttle i could
just look out the window and
enjoy this incredible experience which
it certainly was then all of a sudden
you feel yourself sort of floating up in
your seat
you're weightless i remember unstrapping
and floating over the window and there
was the coast of africa coming over the
horizon
and that's when it really hit me oh my
god i'm in space
[Music]
while launching into space is certainly
an incredible ride
professor hoffman also did a number of
space walks during his career
he shared with us the story of one of
them i remember my very first base walk
on my first space flight
i went out we had to attach some special
tools to the end of the robotic arm
as part of an attempt to rescue a
satellite which had been deployed but
didn't turn on
and then we had been out for about two
hours or so
and the sun set and then they didn't
have the right lighting conditions and
i'll never forget the call that came up
from the ground
hey jeff and dave would you mind staying
outside for another 45 minutes while we
wait for the sun to come
oh my gosh and i had nothing to do i was
just
i mean i was a tourist out in a
spacesuit holding on
i thought to myself i'm just gonna have
some fun
so i actually i was sort of crawling all
over the shuttle
thinking back how i crawled halfway
up the tail and and the commander told
me he was doing his best to keep the tv
cameras off me i mean i just i was so
ecstatic i wasn't
thinking about the fact that you know
maybe some people on the ground wouldn't
want to see an astronaut hanging from
the tail of the shuttle but i did it
it's all a matter of perspective to
broaden your own horizons from the
safety of your own home
be sure to check out professor hoffman's
course materials on mit open courseware
or on the mit open learning library
thanks so much for listening your
comments have inspired me to keep
learning
until next time signing off from
cambridge massachusetts
i'm sarah hansen from mit open
courseware
mom passed the car